hey I'm Priyanka and today I'm going to
give you some tips on how to find your
best fit within the product management
space
before diving into specific job
descriptions it's important to take a
step back and think about the different
types of positions or roles that are
available
one journalist PM a solid generalist
product manager is knowledgeable in the
end-to-end product life cycle they have
the ability to create a Clear Vision and
product strategy in also the roadmap
they also have the ability to actually
execute and launch and take that product
to market for customers these PMs can
adapt very well to lead product and
Engineering teams no matter what
industry sector product domain customer
segment or technology they're asked to
tackle a solid generalist PM is a great
role for new product managers to Aspire
to because the skills can translate so
well to other more specialized PM roles
if you do decide to Branch out later on
in your career at any time
2. inbound or outbound or a mix of both
all product managers build and ship
products or services to their customers
but some of them build products used by
customers outside their Organization for
example a paid application for food
deliveries or a website that is customer
facing these are called outbound PMS
While others focus on products primarily
used internally by the company and they
are called inbound PMS some rules also
offer a mix of both internal facing
roles often emphasize cross-functional
collaboration between internal teams and
the ability to drive consensus for
outbound PMS some additional PM skills
such as Gathering feedback from external
customers or handling customer
Communications as well as working with
product marketing is also important
three B to b or b2c
B2B or business to business product
managers or Enterprise product managers
are Adept at designing and building
products for Enterprise customers B2B
product managers face many challenges
for example the difficulty to have
direct access to customers often having
to go through indirect channels for
feedback but B2B PMS also have the
opportunity to have a broad impact
across a very large customer base also
their work can sometimes shape an entire
industry
b2c or business to consumer product
managers build products for direct
customers who are also often the end
users if you love working on end user
products more directly and want the
ability to get more direct feedback and
measure the impact of your products you
will likely enjoy being a b2c PM
4. more technical or less technical
depending on your industry company or
any specific PM role that you're
applying for you will need to
demonstrate the right level of technical
skills needed to succeed some product
manager roles require very deep and
specific technical skills for example an
artificial intelligence or machine
learning product manager who will need
to demonstrate knowledge of Concepts
such as how a model works or how a model
is trained with data not all product
roles need to be technical you could
come from a ux design or Finance or
business background and still be very
successful as a product manager so if
you're applying for this type of role
maybe more marketing or design oriented
then use your strengths to answer the
interview questions for example if your
ux designer you're already good at
design so start with that during your
interviews and build up from there
5. domain or industry specific product
manager
in today's very competitive job market I
think it's in your advantage to use your
domain and Industry knowledge as your
superpower when interviewing for PM jobs
there are many jobs that are focused on
specific domains or industry sectors for
example a martech PM or marketing
technology pm has experience building
marketing technology related products
you might be a user of those products in
your day-to-day so maybe you use Marketo
or Salesforce marketing Cloud one tip I
have is that you could use this
knowledge that you already have to then
interview for a PM role at a company
that builds those marketing technology
products so by using your strands you
can differentiate yourself from other
candidates and maximize your chances of
getting that PM job I hope this video
helped you learn more about the
different types of product management
roles out there and what your
possibilities are so that you can then
find out role that is the perfect fit
for you
[Music]